- I love this suit.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, with your red hair.
I'm in love with all of you.
- Thank you.
- I would introduce you,
but I hear y'all have made
out before, so yes, yes.
- On a TV show.
- Yeah, yeah, on a TV show.
- [Kelly] On a TV show.
- On his TV show.
- Just backstage, it was weird,
we were like, "Guys, get a room."
No, but how, do you remember the kiss,
either one of you?
- [Both] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, it was this show,
I had a sketch show,
and Jane was on it,
it was a very silly sketch
called "Madison Chooses"
and she was great, and
I played two characters,
the bad boy and the sweet guy.
And we had, I don't know, it was fun.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- You've got her number.
- No I totally remember,
I actually remember,
after you made fun of it.
(clapping and laughter)
And then I remember,
people have asked me.
- Made fun of the kiss?
- Well yeah, I mean it was
awkward, it's like awkward.
People often ask, "Is
it weird to be an actor
and have to kiss people on sets?"
And I also, I remembered this,
but then I was thinking about this story,
I remembered making a movie in 2011,
I had to kiss my costar.
And another costar came
up to me after the kiss,
and was like, "I found a raccoon
trapped in a trashcan once,
and that's how you guys sounded
when you were making out."
(audience laughs)
And I was like...
- Oh my god, way to just
instill the confidence.
- Yeah, I was like, "Thanks."